hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the 1971 candidates series
it's Game seven
Bobby Fischer vs. Tigran Petrosian if
you've been following the match so far
you know the official one first game
Petrosyan one second game then three
guess three of the following games were
drawn and then Fischer won the previous
game with did the black pieces after a
very long struggle and Fischer really
created a masterpiece on the board to
take down the iron team and what with
the black pieces so now it's a
completely different situation in the
match Fischer is leading by a whole
point and he he won against the
Petrosyan with the black pieces
something not not easily accomplished
and now he has the white pieces so now
it's a completely different mindset for
40 grand I'm sure as now he has to catch
up the Fischer he already caught up to
him once because he took him down in
round 2 immediately after Fischer won
Game one but as I said it will be a bit
different because now Fischer did win
with the black pieces and well let's
just see how how things went
it's a really an interesting game and
this is actually the one I made a year
ago some of you already saw the video if
you haven't I will still put a link to
it in the description below if you want
to check out the older version and also
you know an excellent opportunity to
compare channels and to get in the mood
here is a nice photo
there you have it Fischer with the white
pieces Petrosyan is always posing for
the photo
like we said whenever you see a pic a
photo of the grandpa Troezen he will
always look very nice in it especially
here you have this profile photo of
Petrosyan no no that is a nice photo
first is also nice but you know that has
huge smile and petrosian's face that's
really something else so without further
ado Fischer opens with well efore we
have c5 the president goes for the
Sicilian defense 9 to have 3 e 6c d4c
captures Knight captures and now a6 to
the con variation of the Sicilian Bishop
to d3 we have Knight to c6 Knight
captures me captures on c6 and Fischer
castles here we have b5 it's a normal
response you don't want to
a back respond on d7 and here is a very
interesting moment in the game Fischer
plays C 4 and C 4 is an excellent move
if you like playing positions such as
these here with C for Fischer will
definitely create an isolated pawn in in
the center of the board for petrosyan
and will try to create a target of it
that will that that he will use to
attack for the rest of the game so this
is basically deciding what the character
of the game will be so here it doesn't
matter if you capture with the black
here or here whatever you do you will
either have an isolated a and C pawn or
it doesn't matter if you catch capture
here you will also have an isolated and
the C pawn so here after c4 Knight to f6
was played in here we have a series of
exchanges in the center C capture C
captures he captures pawn captures it's
a very interesting Knight captures on d5
seems like a better idea why creates
white create and isolated pawn in the
center but it's actually not not
possible to avoid this because for
example Bishop to b4 and you will force
an isolated pawn regardless of what
black plays for example Queen a4 check
your trade Queens here and then you go
rook to d1 again threatening to capture
here and even if you do something like
Bishop to d6 to you know try to unpin
are still white will simply capture
after you capture nice to see 3 is
coming and white will capture here and
there's no way to avoid pawn captures on
d5 if you move if you move the bishop
then you get Bishop to f4 and now you're
completely lost
there's no way to defend this if you put
the bishop back simply capture now in
Bishop captures Knight captures or you
can simply capture here and then you're
gonna lose a piece so without getting
too much into this pawn captures on d5
Knight to c3 by Fischer Bishop to e7 and
now Queen to a4 our favor gives this
check and he doesn't allow black black
to consolidate and now you can you can
block this check you know with some
different moves for example you can go
Knight to f6 although there's a really
no point in doing this you're completely
losing here first
- capture here and then you're
completely lost but let's say you block
with the bishop blocking with the bishop
is okay but still it's not the greatest
square for the bishop Queen before the
the Queen will be nicely centralized and
black doesn't want to play this
so here Petrosyan doesn't mind trading
Queens now we have Queen to d7 and now
Fischer doesn't capture on b7 but rather
he plays rook to e1 he sees that after
patrols and captures which he did a
Pettersson capture Fischer captured here
he does have a knight on a four but this
will be actually a very nice a nicely
placed Knight an excellently plays
Knight if you will
Bishop to e6 by Petrosyan Bishop to e3
by Fischer we have castles and now
Bishop to c5 it's a very strong square
for the bishop and now if Petrosyan
would trade bishops here then you have
Knight captures on c5 so we have rook F
to e eight petals and rather defenses he
is Bishop we have Bishop captures rook
captures and now B for an excellent move
now if you check out the position in the
board that the material is completely
equal but one big difference is Fischer
has two connected points on the Queen
side and of course at some point you
know that a 4 and B 5 is coming and one
of these points will definitely become a
passed pawn and on the other hand
Patterson has two isolated pawns which
which are not all that easily defendable
so by playing before Fisher already
started his expansion on the Queen side
and also he created a nice outpost
outpost for his night on c5 which is a
nice dark square so okay King to f8
Petrosyan starts bringing his King into
the game unites the c5 as we already
discussed which is again a great move
threatening to capture the bishop here
also there is a double attack against
the a6 pawn here so Bishop to c8 is what
Petrosyan played a 5 isn't all that
great because after a 5 white can
immediately put b5 and already Fischer
has a passed pawn on the Queen side and
whatever black plays even a4 is coming
and then this b5 phone becomes a
protected passed pawn you don't even
have to calculate anything here to
decide you don't know you do not want
white to already have
protected past born on the queenside so
Knights the c5 and now Bishop to c8
petrosyan has to go back with the bishop
to protect the ace exponent now you can
see that the a6 pawn is in fact very
weak f3 fischer simply improves his
position doesn't give this at this night
any squares and prepares some nice
squares for his King to enter the game
rook to a7 the idea is he wants to give
more protection to the SE C exponent to
perhaps activate his Bishop rook to e5
this is an excellent move by Fischer it
really creates sort of a sort of a tube
swung for black because there really
isn't all that many they're really onto
all that many moves he can do you can't
move the knight you have to protect this
pawn if you move back with the rook then
you pretty much admit that your last
move was it wasn't all that great for
example rookie 7 then you get rook e1
simply captures captures and after rook
to a7 it's it's alright but white can
simply ignore you and continue with his
ideas on the Queen side but it wouldn't
be it wouldn't be so terrible after rook
to e5 we have Knight the DS Bishop to d7
Petrosian now tries to activate his
Bishop as he already did place his rocks
here to protect the a6 pawn we have
Knight to d7 now this is the move that
was discussed for for so long and the
idea behind this move is that Fischer
has a monster knight on d5 and this
Bishop here isn't really all that
impressive like it's not really doing
anything it's not really going anywhere
after Bishop d7 there are a couple of
moves you can play here for example you
can go look to see one the most
reasonable move would be simply a 4 not
allowed Bishop to b5 and you simply
continue the game for example a5 b5 is
coming again this Bishop doesn't really
have any good squares if rook to c7
attacking the knight it didn't even work
to c1 you simply continue the game and
it seems like seems like a very nice
position for white but in fact this move
Fischer played after this Bishop
seven after this night capture Sunday
seven like there wasn't a grandmaster
watching this game that wasn't like
totally what is Fischer doing I actually
found a very nice comment on chess
Gamescom I even prepared it here there
you have it by a user off ramp so feel
free to pause the video here and read
this comment because it kind of
perfectly illustrates what kind of what
kind of atmosphere this night captures
on d7 created so I'll give you a couple
of seconds if you you know want to read
it for those of you who have read it
once again congratulations you are an
excellent subscriber and well there
isn't for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show because if you read it
you have enjoyed the show already
so okay night capture Sun d7 we have
rook after Sun b7 and now look the c1
here you can see the idea behind behind
Fischer's a night capture Sun d7 Fischer
now controls the only two opened files
on the board the e-file and the seed
file another thing black still doesn't
have all that many moves he can play he
can't really move this rook away from
the a file because this rook has to keep
an eye on the a6 bone you can't really
move the knight as there are no squares
where you can move it to and you can't
for example move this rook away from the
from the eighth-ranked because you're
gonna get to checkmate it here so not a
lot of moves here to try here but Rosen
tried a rope to d6 he introduces another
defender of the a6 pawn and perhaps I
can activate his rook via rook to e8
Fischer place
rook to c7 now bringing a roof to the
seventh rank is always excellent the
other rook can now come perhaps to e7
and here again it's not all that easy to
decide what to do here if you go
something like rook to e8 then you get
to rope capture speaking captures and
rope to a7 and there's no way for you to
protect the ASX pawn on the other hand
if you try something like rook to e6 the
trade here are you're getting rook
captures pawn captures and again you
still have to keep an eye on this a six
pawn and Fischer will simply waltz in
with the King into the middle of the
board and win the game so Petrosyan
tries a different idea he goes
Knight to d7
what's what's the idea here well of
course officials Rock on e5 is attacked
so we have to move it Fisher moves a
truck to e2 and now g6 creating some
breathing space for the King as
Petrosyan is aware of some back rank
mates that are possible in the position
if he moves the rook King to have to
Fischer simply starts to bring his King
into the game we have h 5 we have F for
h4 and now King to F 3 F 5 and here King
to e3 Fischer starts bring his King into
the center of the board here
you don't really gain anything with rook
to e6 and exchanging works for example
King before
captures captures and now let's say you
go Knight f6 you have to move the night
here Knight is under attack our King
comes into the game you have to move the
knight and now simply captures captures
and captures and now we have an easily
winning game for white so after King to
e3 we have d4 with Czech king to d2 and
now if you there really isn't a move you
can play here once again you have to
keep an eye on the a6 pawn you can't
really move the knight anywhere well it
can go to b6 which was played in the
game you can't move the rook anywhere
the rook has to keep an eye on the night
you can to bring the King closer because
this rock is controlling the e-file
moves like King to f7 are pretty much
pointless you just you're just pinned
here white will simply continue with his
plan of pushing the pawns on the Queen
side so Peterson tries night to b6
Fischer takes this opportunity and
brings his utter rook over to e7 and
okay although nice to d5 was played here
Fischer's rooks are now fourth but it
doesn't really matter rook to f7 check
was played King to e8 and now comes rock
- b7 a very nice move and here Petrosyan
play tonight captures on f4 after this
the game is completely lost but one one
way you could have tried to defend this
rook to b8 but still it would have been
very difficult and of course if you
capture then black will capture your
rook on f7 so let's say rook to a 7 and
now for example if Knight capture some
before you can't really afford to
grabbing any pieces here or pawns
because rope to h7 and you can to defend
checkmate
here for example rook to f6 to try and
block this but again you get to Bishop
to c4 which is the kind of the whole
point of this position rope to a face
simply roughly 7 check King moves now
Bishop to e6 comes and whatever you play
you're you're getting checkmate it
doesn't really matter
one thing you could have tried after
rook to a7 instead of the night capture
some b4
for example Knight back to f6 but still
you get a three and still black would
wouldn't really have anything to do here
bishop would still come to c2 - sorry if
the c2 to b3 and you would again a
control this diagonal and the winning
plan would still be the same
so after this rook to b7 move but rosin
did not play a rock to b8 rather he
played Knight captures on f4 and here we
have Bishop to c4 and after this Bishop
to c4 move Petrosyan saw that there was
nothing he could do and in this position
he resigned the game so yeah what if you
resign well there's really nothing to do
here rook to h7 followed by rock H it is
the threat there's no way to avoid this
whatever you try for example Knight to
e6 if you try Knight to e6 to control
the f8 square you simply get rook to e7
check and now you're gonna lose the
night after King moves you can simply
capture here and that's that's over
another thing after this Bishop captures
Bishop to c4 you can try alright instead
of a 96 perhaps Knight to d5 and now you
lose in a different way simply Bishop
captures on d5 rope captors and rook to
h7 and now there is no move that
prevents Rock to h8 well there are silly
moves but we're not gonna take those
into consideration so yeah after Bishop
to c4
this is move 34 patrols and resigned to
the game and the result is now four and
a half to two and a half in Fischer's
favor and now things are already much
much different and Petrosyan will no
longer have the opportunity of playing
safe for a draw rather he will have to
try to come back in this match how
things will you know turn out you'll
just have to follow this entire match
and and see what happens so yeah it's
very interesting how how this entire
match is going so
for so first we have a game one where
where Petrosyan was better and then he
lost without being able to reach time
control then in game 2 he completely
crushes Fisher game 3 again petrosyan is
better but Fisher draws then we have a
quick game then a really competitive
game but also ends in a draw
Fisher never really better in this match
then we have the previous game where
Petros and chooses a really weird not
weird but a passive ready approach and
Fisher completely crushes him in this
positional masterpiece and then when
Fisher has the white pieces he creates
yet another positional masterpiece and
now well yeah I I think this was one of
one of the grants so worst worst matches
in his life with so much at the stake so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I do hope you enjoy
you're enjoying the Bobby Fischer series
so far I would like to thank Andrew
Clinton Charlotte got Malia professor
dr. Michael Maron
Admiral snack bar and Carl D door for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos your
thank you for watching and I'll see you
soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and we can check out
to this nice comment about night capture
77 for the end of this video once more
there you have it
hope you enjoyed it I'll see you soon